his solution to the u.s. is energy
problems Dean Baker co-director of the
Center for Economic and Policy Research
discusses the growth and what he calls
the predictable collapse of the housing
and stock market bubbles mr. Baker is
critical of both the Reagan and Clinton
administration's and he offers
suggestions for preventing additional
financial crises the event hosted by
Busboys and poets in Washington DC is an
hour
thanks to sort of feel like I should
have a guitar here I have to say you
know and it was snowing I was thinking
wow that's great because now I have a
really good excuse of only four people
show up so somehow you came out anyhow I
guess that's what a good good economic
crash will do I'm going to do is I won't
talk that long because I'm gonna have a
lot of time for questions but I want to
do is start quickly first off give sir
the basic stories what I see is the
origins of the bubble economy then say a
little bit about the stock bubble I like
to be bipartisan here so i get to trash
both Clinton and Bush here so I'll say a
little bit about the stock bubble and
then the housing bubble and then
obviously a little bit about the
collapse and what I see is some of the
key issues going forward including the
stimulus bill that hopefully the house
will pass tomorrow so okay well starting
out the transition how do we get to a
bubble economy I think it is really
important for people understand that we
didn't always have bubble economies and
obviously we had two very big very
dangerous bubbles and last decade or so
but if you look to the post-war period
we had 30 years or so after World War
Two in which the economy had very
healthy growth and really didn't have
any significant bubbles to speak of it
didn't have significant financial
bubbles that doesn't mean they were
never prices that were out of line but
you'd be very hard-pressed if you look
through the economy in the 40s the 50s
the 60s and into the 70s to find any
sort of very erratic movements and asset
prices that really disrupted the economy
and to my mind that was sort of economy
we'd like to see that you had a
situation where you had very good
economic growth economy was growing
rapidly productivity was growing rapidly
was broadly shared so that crossed the
book board up and down the income ladder
you saw rising real incomes typical
workers were seeing their wages rise
more or less and stuff with productivity
growth and I'd argue that that's not an
economy that's conducive to bubbles that
of course changed as we got into the 70s
and then most importantly by
deliberately deliberate policy changes
with President Reagan coming into office
in 1980 basically President Reagan and
adopted a set of policies that were
quite deliberately designed to weaken
the power of workers weaken the power of
unions and to redistribute income
upwards and it certainly had that
fact so mayonnaise policies as though
things were all familiar with certainly
the weakening of unions President Reagan
quite deliberately tried to weaken the
power of organized labor he appointed
people in National Labor Relations Board
there were much more hostile to unions
it made it much more difficult to
organize everyone remembers the air
traffic controllers he fired the air
traffic controllers when they went on
strike they really changed the norms of
labor management relations because prior
to the firing the air traffic
controllers employers did not fire
striking workers it simply you know
skeletal staff you kept some management
personnel but the deal was could you
outlast your workers your workers from
getting a paycheck you weren't selling
anything that was the deal that was the
context in which negotiations took place
immediately after President Reagan fired
the air traffic controllers are a whole
set of instances in which major
companies Eastern Airlines was one
Greyhound bus company where they fired
their workers when they went out on
strike totally changed the dynamics of
Labor Relations going out on strike
meant you could lose your job it
obviously made a much more effective
weapon for workers for unions against
employers well that was part of a larger
set of changes that the Reagan Reagan
administration put in place a weakened
the power of Labor it wasn't just the
union's trade policy we had a trade
policy that was quite explicitly
designed to put to put our manufacturing
workers in direct competition with
low-wage low paid workers in the
developing world and the predicted
effect of that the predict an actual
effect of that is that it drives down
the wages of manufacturing workers the
United States and in fact because
manufacturing at the time certainly was
a major pace place of employment of
good-paying jobs for workers without
college degrees that had the effect of
drying driving down the wages of workers
without college degrees more generally
also deregulation of major sectors like
trucking like the airline industry that
also had the effect of weakening the
power of workers in those industries
those were places where workers non non
college-educated workers had relatively
good paying jobs the high dollar way to
high dollar in the 80s I'll come back to
this we had a high dollar in the middle
of the 80s that led to a large trade
deficit again that
at imp editing peated the
competitiveness of our manufacturing
industry put more downward pressure on
the wages of manufacturing workers so we
had a variety of policies that weaken
the power of working people in the
country and what it meant was that
workers no longer were in a position to
share in the gains of productivity
growth so this created the environment
or so I would argue it created the
environment in which you could have a
bubble economy prior to the Reagan era
you had a situation of this virtuous
cycle where you had productivity growth
translate into wage growth translate
into consumption increased demand
increased investment increased
productivity growth wages etc you broke
that cycle when wage is no longer kept
pace with with productivity growth and
you created an environment in which
bubbles can grow okay so when do we
first start seeing the bubbles well we
didn't see any significant bubbles in
the 80s the bubbles first became an
issue in the 90s with the Clinton
administration they don't argue that
President Clinton pursued a policy is
his keys central tenets of his
macroeconomic policy which is very
conducive to a growth of a bubble both
his focus on Deficit Reduction and also
his deregulation are called one-sided
deregulation the financial sector I'll
come to the one sided in a minute his
the central tenant of President
President Clinton's economic policy was
deficit reduction we have to get
deficits down and many you may recall
when he first came into office he sort
of was torn we'll see how President
Obama deals with this tension very
shortly I imagine but he was torn
between all these commitments he had
made towards investing in people putting
people first if you remember his
platform on the other hand all the
deficit hawks led by Robert Rubin who
became his Treasury secretary of course
saying no we have to get the deficits
down that's what really has to be front
and center and of course the deficit
hawks were the ones that worn out he
largely abandoned his public investment
program the idea of putting a lot of
money into education infrastructure
research and development that was
largely abandoned in favor of the
deficit reduction side of the story so
what was that supposed to do well the
deficit reduction story was we get the
deficit down lowers interest rates were
supposed to increase investment and the
increase in investment is supposed to
make up for the lost demand if we reduce
the deficit that means we're either
raising taxes which of course President
Clinton did and or cutting spending he
also cut spending he did do both okay so
that's reducing demand you make that up
with increased investment so that was
sort of the classic story of what was
supposed to happen okay well part of
that did happen we did get very low
interest rates so if you look back to
the 90s we did get very low interest
rates we did get some up ticket
investment but the real part of that
story what really happened and led the
economy the economic growth which we
actually obviously did have very good
economic growth towards the end of the
90s what really led that was a stock
bubble so we had a very low interest
rate environment that was one that was
very conducive for the growth of the
stock bubble and we saw that stock
prices hit levels ratios to corporate
earnings so we'd never seen before at
least not since the 20s i'm not expert
enough on what the 20s looked like so I
couldn't tell you price-to-earnings
ratios then but historically the price
to earnings ratio and the stock market
had been around 14 14 21 14 15 21 so
stock prices were equal to roughly 14
times corporate profits in the late 90s
that rose over to over 20 to 1 by 95 and
by the end of the decade across 30 to 1
okay this should have been easy to
recognize as a bubble by the way it
didn't have to you didn't take a great
genius a lot of people were surprised
they lost a lot of money they probably
deserved at least many of them but it
should have been easy to recognize when
you saw price-earnings ratios that got
to these ridiculous levels in the late
nineties I'm saying this remembering
that I had to argue with a lot of people
because they're a lot of people who
thought it was a great idea to put
Social Security money in the stock
market back then they just said we'll
just put it there and we'll all be rich
you know but it should have been easy to
recognize that you had a stock bubble in
the late 90s but for the most part
certainly the folks the policy people
here in Washington for the most part
didn't recognize that and they continued
to act like Oh everything's just fine
with the stock market and for the time
through the late 90s that was actually
what drove the economy so if you look at
what were the sources of growth and late
90s there was a little bit of an
increase in investment so you actually
had reasonably good investment that
story's exaggerated because a lot of the
the Clinton nights would like to say all
investment sword that's not true
can tell you more carefully about why
that's not true but there was some
uptick investment some of that was
directly related to stock bubble so for
one of those one these rare occasions
where stock purchases stock prices
actually led to investment because you
had the classic story of companies
selling stock the internet companies
selling stock and using have to finance
investment that's not usually something
happens that did happen a little bit in
the late 90s but what really fueled the
economy the strong growth that we saw
the late 90s was consumption based on
stock wealth there's a well-known wealth
effect that a comest have written about
god knows how long that relates
consumption to to stock wealth on the
order of about three or four cents on
the dollar and by my calculations we had
roughly 10 trillion dollars of bubble
wealth in the stock market at the peak
of the bubble which translated at three
or four cents on the dollar into three
or four hundred billion a year an
additional consumption or measured
relative to GDP that was three to four
percent of GDP that's a lot of money
today that'd be the equivalent of about
four hundred fifty billion to six
hundred billion a year of additional
consumption and that fits the data very
well you see savings rates fall very low
they felt about 2% at the end of the
decade so the basic story was that in
the late 90s we did have this very good
growth it wasn't the story that the
Clinton people like to tell it wasn't
really investment-led it was led by the
stock bubble and that promoted
consumption and it got the unemployment
rate down to four percent I think all of
us were very happy to see that there
were at that point good wage gains for
workers up and down the income ladder
but the real problem with this story was
that it wasn't sustainable because
there's a bubble it couldn't last and
eventually burst the story wide berths
was you eventually ran out of people are
willing to pay hundreds of millions of
dollars for doc garbage and you know
prices fell so you got to 2000 March to
2000 and Nasdaq hit 5000 by the summer
was down to 3,000 and by the next summer
it was down to about 1100 went start to
plunge I remember I had a friend it had
fallen to as I said had fallen about
3200 that summer I remember I came
across a friend who I think probably had
a lot of money the Nasdaq they didn't
want to tell me that but I made some
comment about the stock market falling
further and he said well not
NASDAQ and I said no I could fall
further and he said well how well you
think it can go yeah it's already gone
from 5000 3200 and as I okay go to 1600
you know literally was just picking a
number out of the air and then then
about a year later went to 1600 I was
trying to decide whether I should call
him or not to tell him that wasn't a buy
recommendation as I say it eventually
did bottom out i think it was around
1100 and summer 2002 but in any case
that wasn't sustainable and of course
that collapsed so it was we had four
good years 96 to 2000 unemployment was
down wages were growing a lot of good
things you could say about an economy
during those periods but it clearly
wasn't a sustainable story now another
part of the story that that was very
important and I think I and many other
people over looked at the time the forum
points of it we had the strong dollar
policy and this this again it's
something that's very perverse I had
this argument all these economist cuz
we've learned one thing we're in grad
school now they say something completely
on the other side no one ever
acknowledges like aren't you saying the
opposite of what you taught us you know
I mean I used to have a this thing that
I had to argue with mainstream economist
now I realized I don't have to argue i
just have to write down what they said
and repeat it back to him but anyhow the
story that we were all taught in grad
school and in fact all economists would
have said until the mid-90s when sort of
flipped on us was that when you got the
deficit down part of the good things
that were supposed to happen was you had
lower interest rates the dollar was
supposed to fall why is that good well
when the dollar falls our exports become
cheaper so people buy more of them we
export more and imports become more
expensive to people living the united
states so we'll import less that that's
supposed to get rid of the trade deficit
and there's whole literature totally
mainstreamed center of the discipline
literature that talked about the twin
deficits we had a high trade deficit in
the 80s beginning in the 90s because we
had a high budget deficit so he said
we'll get the budget deficit down you'll
get interest rates down get the dollar
down and then we'll improve our trade
balance so getting the getting the
budget deficit down was supposed to get
the dollar down okay well they flip that
around in the late 90s and no one ever
bothered to tell us that suddenly
getting the deficit down
got the dollar up made no sense but
everyone repeated that so you had Robert
Rubin running around strong dollar we
got the deficit down therefore we have a
strong dollars total nonsense but in any
case that was the official line the
reality was that the reason the dollar
went up in the late 90s was in part also
result of conscious policy the way we
dealt with the east asian financial
crisis the United States which obviously
directs the IMF took a very big hand in
dealing with East Asian financial crisis
in 97 we imposed very harsh conditions
on these countries basically saying you
have to pay back your debts and the way
they were able to pay back their debts
was there to export like crazy and how
did the export like crazy if you're
South Korea Thailand Malaysia picked
these countries you devalue your
currency so the flipside of them having
a low currency we had a high currency
they exported like crazy to us we ran
very large trade deficits and that
continued through the end of the decade
into this decade so we had a trade
deficit that ultimately peaked at about
six percent of our economy in 2006 again
in today's dollars would be about nine
hundred billion dollars she had a huge
trade deficit it was caused by the high
dollar that's that was the cause of the
trade deficit ok so my reason for
mentioning that is okay so we get the
crash of the stock bubble the economy
goes into recession in 2001 March of
2001 officially if you talk to comments
they say oh that was a real mild
recession you know it lasted just from
March of 2001 to November of 2001 just
seven months about short as a recession
could be and you know instead was a very
mild recession what's the big deal well
the reality of course was it wasn't a
mild recession i mean we could date the
recession's wherever we want that's
arbitrary but the point is what happened
in 2001's we lost jobs we continue to
lose jobs long after the recession ended
so officially ends in november of 2001
we continue to shed jobs all through
2002 we didn't actually start creating
jobs again till the fall of two thousand
three so as a very long period we went
without creating any jobs now part of
that story was the high dollar policy
typically what happens in a recession is
you expect to see improvement on your
trade balance you expect import less you
often will export more we didn't see
that our trade deficit kept
rolling that was a high-dollar problem
we didn't do anything about that a lot
of people seem to think that was good
policy okay well what was the other part
of the story how do you get the economy
going well Greenspan sitting there going
well the economy's dead in the water
it's not creating jobs what do you do
you lower interest rates he was right to
do that is a very weak economy there
wasn't much else he could do okay well
what else did he do well the only real
source of life in the economy at that
point was the housing bubble and what I
would say and I don't have personal
contact with Greenspan but what I would
say is he deliberately fostered the
growth of the housing bubble he did a
lot of things at different points that
would seem to indicate he wanted the
housing bubble to grow first and
foremost what he did was he denied that
there was a bubble I first began to look
at the housing market i mean i found the
housing market a macroeconomist I filed
a housing market like I follow the
energy market or the auto industry
that's typically how I file the housing
market I first began to look at the
housing market very closely because in
the summer of 2002 Greenspan was giving
testimony before Congress and he made a
big point of saying how there is no
housing bubble and I read his testimony
and I looked at the reasons he gave no
them in a sense okay so he said well why
our house prices at that point you could
always see house prices had vastly
outstripped the rate of growth of
inflation so prior to prior to the house
prices began to rise the mid-90s
interestingly corresponding with the
stock bubble but prior to the mid-90s
you can go back a hundred years house
prices have just kept even with the
overall rate of inflation that's a
national average because I know you
could all tell me about California in
New York or this place of that place but
as a national average house price is
just risen at the same rate as the price
of other goods and services so car
prices close the average of other goods
and services they resent the same rate
that changes in the mid-nineties they
suddenly begin to rise much more rapidly
than other prices and by 2002 that risen
by about thirty percent after you adjust
for inflation from their mid 90s level
so Greenspan goes before Congress and
goes well we don't have a housing bubble
the reason why that's happening he goes
well on the demand side it's because
we've had rapid growth in income now you
go then that makes sense we did have
good growth obviously in late 90s but by
the time he's talking
we've already been in the recession
income it stopped growing that really
didn't make much sense furthermore the
income growth round the late nineties
wasn't that good it wasn't any better
than the income growth we had for a
quarter century at the end of World War
two and that didn't produce any bubble
so there was no real story their income
growth the other thing he said I really
loved is again speaks to the way
economists work he said well the other
thing that's driving it up on the demand
side is population growth which the
reason why I found that so incredible
because one of the other areas that I'm
arguing with people is social security
and you recall the problem of Social
Security's populations not growing so so
over here Alan Greenspan's talking about
population growth causing up big rise in
house prices over here he's with all the
other people saying oh my god we have
this horrible problem with Social
Security you know we started our
populations not growing you know we'll
give you one or other you don't get both
so that didn't make any sense he also
said immigrants he blamed on immigrants
ago I don't think immigrants are buying
four hundred fifty thousand dollar homes
over in California and it really didn't
make a lot of sense so that was the
demand side of the story his supply side
he goes well we we have a fixed amount
of you know buildable land in our cities
and you know yeah that's not exactly new
furthermore again I started like you
know you get one argument over here in
the opposite over there we've just been
through the new economy where
limitations of time and space didn't
matter anymore now that of course was to
large extent nonsense but it's not total
nonsense in a sense that it's possible
to telecommute in a way today that
wasn't true certainly 15 or 20 years ago
so there are limitations of space
there's only so many people could live
in downtown DC or whatever but those
limitations were probably less binding
in the Internet age than they were 10 or
15 years earlier so there wasn't a real
good story the other thing he talked
about was environmental restrictions on
building and again you just sort of go
well the timing here isn't quite right i
mean the republicans had taken over
congress in 1994 they weren't big
environmentalists for the most part
they've taken over many state houses so
if we wanted to tell a story that
environmental restrictions on building
were limiting the supply of housing this
probably wasn't the time that would be
true and if we really want to check on
that well why don't we just look at how
many homes were building and that was
easy enough to do and you could find
that we're building homes at near-record
rate and that was through all through
this period 2002 through 2006
so he didn't have a story in the supply
so I didn't have a story on the demand
side the last part of the story if you
want to check here is you just go well
what's going on with rents because at
the end of the day there is to some
extent one housing market I mean we know
most people would rather buy than rent
but if those prices get radically out of
line you get people move into a city
they're going to make a decision rent or
people forming their own household for
the first time moving away from their
parents if they're hugely out of line
they're going to decide to rent rather
than by so we expect that those prices
to more or less move together and if you
look at what was going on with rents the
answer was nothing they rose a little
bit more in the rate of inflation
through the late 90s but by 2001-2002
they'd flattened out and actually from
Moses period rents actually weren't even
keeping pace with rate of inflation so
in short there was no story based on the
fundamentals it was pretty clear that
you had a bubble and ul and Greenspan
deliberately going out of his way to
deny it okay so he did a couple other
things along the way that I would argue
fostered the bubble some of you might
recall that in in the in the fall of two
thousand three when interest rates fixed
interest rates a 30-year mortgage was at
that time near 50-year low we've since
gotten lower but at that time is near
its 50-year low he encouraged people to
take out adjustable rate mortgages okay
so that was a sort of thing you know
again not everyone listens tail and
Greenspan directly and deciding what's
our mortgage to take out but obviously
his words get passed on so that you have
if you didn't directly here Alan
Greenspan maybe your friend did maybe a
realtor did maybe your mortgage broker
did that was a green light to people to
take out adjustable rate mortgages which
was a very peculiar practice given that
you can get a record low rate on
fixed-rate mortgages okay so i could
give you a few other things as to why i
think he was fostering the bubble but
long and short he certainly did nothing
to rein in its growth and on top of that
we had this whole pattern of financial
as I say one-sided deregulation dating
from the Clinton era and certainly
Greenspan continued that where they let
incredible abuses incredibly risky
practices take place on financial sector
and my reason for preferring to term
one-sided deregulation rather than just
saying deregulations I think it's
important to not give these people the
benefit
or more in the benefit out not let them
be dishonest about their views because
they always were benefiting from
government insurance in the form of the
too-big-to-fail doctrine and what that
meant was when all these guys are going
out there saying oh we don't want the
government just give us a free hand you
know really smart people we run
Citigroup we were on goldman sachs we
don't need the government to tell us
what to do well at the end of the day
they knew that the government was going
to come in and bail them out or at least
bail their creditors out and their
creditors knew that basically what they
had was an insurance policy that they
didn't want to pay for it gives them way
too much credit to call the market
fundamentalist that gives them way too
much credit they're not market
fundamental as i like to call nanny
state conservatives they wanted the
government to give them a very valuable
insurance policy they didn't want to
have to pay for it okay that's how we
should understand these people okay well
anyhow obviously what goes on through
this period house prices go through the
roof they eventually rise by almost
eighty percent when you adjust for
inflation in many of the bubble markets
to some extent DC in the East Coast but
the biggest bubble markets are places
like Las Vegas California Florida prices
more than doubled after adjusting for
inflation this is where you saw the
worst activity in terms of people
getting adjustable rate mortgages that
there was no way on earth they could
afford many cases interest-only loans
buying homes putting zero money down
okay we had a whole set of practices
that just should jumped out at anyone
that this was not sustainable this was
going to end very badly Greenspan my
favorite villain here one of the
remarkable things anyone was paying
attention to this should have known
subprime mortgages exploded as a share
of the market they had been around out
of when you first had somebody was
identifiable subprime but they've been
around a long time seven eight nine
percent of the market they explode to be
twenty-five percent of the market in
2005 now Greenspan the summer was quoted
in The Washington Post the saying well
he just discovered that his last month
in January 2006 he said he saw a very
disturbing statistics he saw that that
subprime were twenty five percent of the
market he was very disturbed by that and
then at least he told the post he said
he couldn't remember whether he passed
this information on to Ben Bernanke
now again it's I don't know which is
worse that you know Greenspan is lying
about this or if that's actually true I
man it's a tough one I don't know I
don't know but long in chart i mean
these were the sorts of practices that
it should have been evident to anyone
whose business it was to follow the
economy that we had a very serious
bubble here and it was going to end very
badly well how does it end how do all
bubbles end well just as what the stock
bubble you run out of suckers okay house
prices kept going up we kept building
more houses okay vacancy rates are
rising this is all you know it's amazing
the the Commerce Department this Bureau
puts out vacancy rates every quarter I
think I was like the only person in
country ever paid attention to them
because I talk about it I tell you the
reporters I go where'd you get that
looks right on their website you know
it's not it's not it's not secret data
so so vacancy rates were soaring well
what does that mean again this you don't
have to be some sort of crazy radical
economist you have a big increase in
supply it exceeds demand you have a lot
of excess houses sitting there vacant
what's that gonna do to the price I mean
that isn't that hard but it was a big
surprise the boys on Wall Street at
Goldman Sachs Citibank and everyone else
suddenly price started falling home
prices were resetting mortgages
resetting and what you had when the
mortgage is reset this is a two-fold
problem is sent the center part of the
problem is that the house prices had
fallen it's remarkable to me how many
comments still don't understand that
central part of the problem was that
house prices had fallen the other part
is that people can no longer for their
monthly payments my reason for saying
the central part of the problem is that
house prices had fallen if house fires
are kept rising who cares you know so
your mortgage reset you'd had a five
percent mortgage it goes up to nine
percent at six percent goes to ten
percent well if your house price is
going up by twenty percent you just run
down to the bank and get new mortgage
and that's a lot of people have been
doing and as long as your house price
keeps going up that's fine you can keep
doing that forever the problem is will
instead of going up twenty percent your
house price goes down twenty percent see
borrow 250,000 on a home that today is
worth 200,000 that was the problem that
was the underlying problem house prices
fell okay and obviously this cascaded so
once you had a situation where house
prices start falling people began to
expect them to fall you saw higher
default rates higher foreclosure rates
well welcome to 2009 okay so we get this
downward spiral everything goes in
reverse instead of construction driving
up the economy at its peak instructions
about six percent of GDP residential
construction it collapses it's now three
percent gdp we're building homes less
than half the rate that we were just
just two years ago just three years ago
so residential construction collapses
that's a huge hit to the economy but
then the more serious hit is that his
house prices collapse all the money that
people thought they had in their home
all their equity just disappeared okay
by my calculations at the peak of the
bubble in 2006 we had close to eight
trillion dollars in housing bubble
wealth that's the difference between
prices as they were in 2006 and prices
where they would have been if they just
follow their trend level a trillion
dollars translates into 110 thousand
dollars for every homeowner in the
country that's disappearing now we've
lost roughly three-quarters of that
we've lost roughly six trillion dollars
in housing bubble wealth so what does
that mean a lot of people that thought
they had 200,000 equity in their home
they might have 50,000 you have more
than 10 million people are now under
water in their homes they all mourn the
value of their home so apart from the
people that are losing their home
through foreclosure because they can't
make the mortgage payments other
population as a whole has seen trillions
of dollars of wealth disappear and as a
result of that they're consuming a lot
less in some cases because they have no
option you can't if you have no equity
in your home you can't borrow against it
to take a vacation by a car in some
cases just pay your living expenses you
can't do that if you don't have any
equity to borrow against in other cases
they're realizing you have people we
have this huge baby boom cohort that is
close to retirement and allow them are
realizing they don't have any money they
also saw of course the collapse of stock
market cut the value their 401ks by
thirty or forty percent so now they
realize they don't have long to
retirement they have to get very serious
about saving so there's not a great
mystery as to why you get into a
downturn when you see a collapse of the
housing market destroys six trillion and
wealth coupled again we could talk about
the stock market losing on the order of
seven or eight trillion and wealth now
add to all this we get our nice
financial crisis to throw in again it's
not a surprise you get financial
Isis when you get a collapse of a
housing bubble housings always highly
leveraged ass that I mean even go back
to the good old days we were all buying
homes putting twenty percent down well
that went 2-0 down in law cases in 2003
2004-2005 I remember a survey of the the
Realtors forty-two percent of first-time
homebuyers in two thousand five with
zero down pretty incredible statistic
again if Alan Greenspan were awake he
would have noticed that so in any case
it's not a surprise that you get a
financial crisis because you have a very
heavily leveraged asset that's just lost
much of its value so all these banks are
sitting there with mortgages that are
worth a fraction of what they were when
they issued them and obviously the fact
that they were issuing them in complex
instruments collateralized debt
obligations we had all sorts of
financial mechanics being in being put
in place by our friends on Wall Street
that made them that much more vulnerable
to this sort of downturn by the way I
always find it amusing where they keep
saying no one could have envisioned this
Robert Rubin was quoted that saying that
no one could have envisioned this a it
is incredible that you could have
someone I hate I know I don't hate to
pick on Robert Rubin I like to pick on
Robert Rubin that someone he made 120
million at Citibank and he said he had
nothing to do with any of this you sort
of wonder what he was getting paid for
but but when you say no one could have
envisioned this I just can't imagine
that you really had people sitting at
Citibank and what not one of them looked
at this and thought there could be a
problem here I mean it really is
mind-boggling it is it is little
mind-boggling so any out that aside so
where are we now so we've seen a
collapse of housing market collapsed a
consumption and the economy is
essentially in a freefall I mean this is
really it's very scary I mean the amount
of job loss that we had over the last
three months the last quarter 2008 we
lost more than 500,000 jobs a month this
is almost unprecedented and what scares
me is that I think is actually
accelerating so all of you probably
heard the the layoffs yesterday
caterpillar announced 20,000 intel
announced i think it was six thousand
and it's really cross sectors that the
pharmaceutical industry Pfizer I think
sat eight thousand so it's yeah retail
circuit city just shut down that was
thirty three thousand jobs so it's bad
as the job loss was through the fall it
looks like it might even be good more
rapid in January and presumably februari
me on same thing to sort turn the
picture around very soon which is why
Congress better past that stimulus
package very quickly because we really
do need that to turn the economy around
so I was on a show last night with
opposite some guy from the Heritage
Foundation and I made some comment about
the key with stimulus is you have to
spend money and I saw that they put up
on their website go now we have those
liberals there he is he just said it
yeah and I'll say it again if they
wanted you know where our learned c-span
so they could you know get it again you
have to spend money that may sound
stupid but that's the key to get out of
this sort of downturn now obviously it's
better to spend money on things that are
good that will help people today make us
more productive in the future if we
could build infrastructure I'll make it
more productive if we could you retrofit
our homes so that they use less energy
all that is great but first and foremost
the key right now is we got to spend
money we're spiraling downward and it
makes much more sense to spend money on
things that might not be the best thing
in the world then sit there going well
maybe we could spend over here you know
we'll take listening Republicans I think
they want to spend the next year
figuring out where we spend the money in
the meantime we're going to lose another
five million jobs so that's a little
wacky so I mean that's the short term
story the problem with the Obama plan is
I think it's not big enough but I mean
I'd still say this is a start get it out
there we're going to have to do more but
that's a very very good start now just
very quickly over the longer term what
we have to do is talk about having a
very different type of economy we have
to talk about game back to the sort of
economy we had in the post-war period
where people could share where everyone
shares in the gains of economic and
productivity growth I won't give you all
the recipes for that I have them in
another book but but no I won't give you
all the recipes but the one thing I will
says we have to contain the financial
sector I mean we have to treat the
financial sector I'll be crude area and
say we I treat them like a cancer I mean
we do not want a big financial sector I
guess is again just common sense an
economist on the dais they're being
honest will agree with this the
financial sector is an intermediate good
it's like trucking imagine where the
trucking industry where it employed ten
percent of our labor force we have 14
million people employing trucking well
any person i right mind the actual
numbers about 1.4 million by 1% any
person that right mind will go well you
really have a blow to trucking sector
it's really inefficient
and they'd be right why would you want
ten percent of your workforce moving
goods around we could do with one
percent well it's the same thing with
finance finance is supposed to be there
to serve the productive economy it's
supposed to be there so that when we
want to get a mortgage wanna borrow
money to start a business or expand a
business who want to save money for our
kids education for a retirement that's
why we have finance it's not an end in
itself it's not like healthcare or
recreation it's not something we're
going to feel better because we have
more finance that's crazy so we had this
explosion in this sector over the last
30 years that really was in effect a
parasite on the rest economy is draining
resources from the rest of the economy
and ultimately jeopardize the rest
economy and led to the economic disaster
we're seeing so i think the policies we
put in place should be deliberately
designed to rein in the financial sector
one of the things i've been very fond of
is just a very modest financial
transactions tax if you text stock
trades say about 2500 so one percent no
one's going to like paying that i know
that but the reality of the matter is
that for people who are buying stock to
hold for five years 10 years 20 years
that's a really inconsequential fee
that's that we used to pay more when you
bought stock 20 30 years ago because
transaction costs are higher then it's a
really inconsequential fee on the other
hand for people are buying stock at one
o'clock and selling it a two that's a
very big fee okay so it would discourage
a lot of speculation would keep the
financial sector from growing as big as
it's gotten and I say that's really
important for a couple reasons one I'd
love the idea of getting revenue that
way and by my estimates i did paper with
my friend Bob pole and a few years ago
we estimate you can get over a hundred
billion a year from attacks like that's
real money okay so you get a lot of
money that way you keep the sector's
size down and I'd say that's important
not just because you make it more
efficient but at the end of the day what
was really key in our failure to
regulate the sector wasn't that you
didn't have people who knew what was
going on because at different points you
did so for example Brooks labaran who
was head of the Commodity Futures
Trading Commission in 98 wanted to rein
in she wants to regulate derivatives she
wants to regulate credit default swaps
who have been great thing if she had
done that she wasn't able to do that
because you had people like Robert Rubin
who came down on her like a ton of
bricks and said no you can't
that okay and robert rubin a political
clout she dint so she was overruled in
this decade Ned Gramlich who was one of
the members of board of governors
unfortunately passed on last year but he
went to Greenspan ease he saw what was
going on he said you know we've this
real problem we have all these
low-income people are buying these
complex subprime mortgages they don't
understand that we could regulate that
Greenspan waved him away and said I'm
not interested there are few other
instances like that where you had people
who wanted to do the right thing but
they weren't able to because the people
with political power prevented them from
doing that and my takeaway from that is
that one of the problems of the
financial sector has too much political
power and it's going to have too much
political power if we let it to get to
be a big powerful industry so that's
another argument I think a very
important argument for reining it in
because we could write all the best
rules in the world and you've got all
these people running around town on all
my conference I've been in the last six
months about writing the new rules and
we need good rules but you also need
them enforced and if you don't have a
political situation that allows you to
effectively enforce the rules the rules
don't matter so that's another reason
why I think it's very important to write
in the financial sector they're going to
have their one-sided insurance policy no
matter what I don't see a way we can get
around too big to fail so we have to
make sure that they pay a price for it
they don't get it for free which means
we need serious regulation and that to
my mind means we have a small financial
sector so just in conclusion I want to
say that you know we have incredible
amount of opportunities and I may I
don't think I'm any disparaging remarks
about Obama because I don't very happy
to see him in the White House I think we
have incredible opportunities here and I
really hope we're in a position and take
advantage of them and we do take
advantage of them to the fullest and you
know steel line from his chief of staff
Rahm Emanuel akright you should never
waste a crisis so let's not waste it
thanks
okay so take questions I guess it's just
one mic there hi I enjoyed your talk um
could you please tell me what you think
about the new treasury secretary what
she had paid his taxes yeah I have some
concerns about the new Treasury
Secretary Tim Geithner fervor people not
familiar he played a central role in the
Clinton administration in engineering
the east asian financial bailout he was
at the new york fed as much of this was
going on he basically he missed the
story and i'm not sure as conduct even
after things start to fall apart was too
much better and this is one of these
things i find very perverse if you look
at someone's track record because people
have asked me about larry summers of
course is the head of President Obama's
national economic council and the
summers are very bright guys are in a
lot of good economics pieces but the
fact was he was in the center the
Clinton administration he supported the
policies that got us here and if you
raised that point well let's look at
their track record people are looking
like why would you be so vindictive it
seems like a reasonable thing to do and
and I said it for a very important
reason that you one of the problems here
is that you have a totally a symmetric
structure of incentives I mean I don't
think I was uniquely brilliant to being
able to see the bubble the issue was I
wasn't served in the same hierarchies as
Tim Geithner and these other people were
and from their vantage point if they had
done what I did Tim guy from the three
years ago it got announced we have a
really big bubble this is really bad
cause lots of problem he would have had
Greenspan all these other people go Tim
you nuts you know you want to lose your
job you know you know he had to worry
about that so he had a very asymmetric
set of incentives that suppose he saw
exactly what I did he thought exactly
the way I did well he'd go well I could
do what Baker's doing but I'm really
gonna run in trouble particularly if I'm
wrong because none of us could be
absolutely certain were right on the
other hand if I just go Oh everything's
okay everything's great there's no
housing bubble everything's fine well he
was really wrong but does anyone hold
against them now he's Treasury secretary
so if you don't do anything about that
structure of incentives you have this
totally one-sided pressure
are where everyone's just going to say
what their boss says what the higher-ups
a everything's fine why would you ever
do otherwise so guys may be very very
good but we're not going to get the
benefit of his wisdom if he's just doing
what the person on top of him says and
that's true for all these economist all
these people in policy positions so I
wasn't happy to send picked his Treasury
secretary
I'm not sure if it was mentioned in the
introduction I just want to make sure
that people know about Dean's blog is a
great resource and a great way to be
learning about things contemporaneously
I guess you just Google Dean Baker it'll
be the first thing we press on the
American process American prospects
website I'd love to get your analysis of
tarp and where we go from here I mean I
I was what was your analysis of the
giveaway if that was necessary I am Lulu
I felt a little weird the last several
months they've all been all these
progressive economists not just you but
a lot of progressive icon whose main
mission seems to be to save the capital
structure and and there's and I
understand that because we don't want a
lot of people hurt but there is a sort
of eerie feel to the whole thing so a
tarpon where we go from here regarding
okay well I actually was an opponent of
the tarp bill I it was actually a
fascinating story having been to some
extent the middle I don't know if I was
that much in little bit but I was
talking number of members of Congress
and their staffers as I was being
debated and I felt a couple things first
off it was being very much
misrepresented to the public there was
this real effort to create a greater
sense of crisis than there was now the
financial system was in very bad shape
at that point I wouldn't deny that for a
second was it on the edge of collapse
that we actually have to pass the the
tarp that day well I think none i think
Henry Paulson proved that because he
didn't do anything with the money for 10
days after he had full legal authority
to do whatever he wanted with it so
obviously he didn't think it was that
urgent but we did have the this effort
to say there was this great urgency and
it was it was striking I mean one of the
issues that was fascinating to me was
they claim that if we didn't the to my
mind the immediate urgency if there was
a case out there we had to do something
that day it wasn't that the bank's
weren't lending to each other that was a
problem but what really was threatening
was if you got to a situation where
companies could not do business so the
story was yet an otherwise healthy
company of verizon that fine profits and
I'm not doing to do a plug for Verizon
but it's not about to go out of business
and they couldn't borrow the money
commercial paper market to pay their
meat their payroll pay their bills now
that happens the economy shuts down so
the argument was that was happening I
think that was overplayed there was some
evidence something like that was
happening well after the tarp was passed
that weekend Ben Bernanke the fellow
Reserve Board Chairman announced that he
was going to buy up commercial paper of
non-financial companies well why is that
important well it's important for two
reasons one if he could buy up the paper
of non-financial companies we don't have
to worry about verizon not having the
money money to meet their payroll the
other reason why i was so striking at
least to me was i didn't know the Fed
had that authority and if the Fed had
that authority you had to ask or at
least I asked why didn't you do that
before Congress voted the Fed is not
supposed to be in the business of
manipulating congressional votes and I
think they did that now they weren't the
only ones the media and this is almost
across the board I never saw the media
come down with such uniformity on an
issue where if you were against the tarp
you are basically a knuckle scraping
neanderthal which is really striking
because a lot of very prominent
economist were against the tap it wasn't
just me and a few kind of crazy Lee
fringe lefties they were there was a
letter that came out from the University
of Chicago that was signed by hundreds
of economists many of them very
prominent commas saying we don't have to
do this it's not urgent this is a well
thought through this isn't the way to do
it so but nonetheless the media was
portraying it that if you didn't support
the tarp you were your knuckles scraping
the end earth all and at the end of the
day they literally made it impossible
for members of Congress to vote against
it and I again I said this from having
talked with them because they had
created this situation remember when it
went down the first time the the market
fell by about ten percent that day the
dow fell by a thousand points the
immediately rushed out and said you just
destroyed one trillion dollars of wealth
it was like an idiot thing to say but
that was that's what they were sayin I
could go on about why there's an idiot
thing to say so the members of Congress
have voted against it just destroyed a
trillion dollars of wealth well they
created the situation where it was very
clear that the people if the tarp went
down the people voted against that we're
going to be blamed for every bad thing
that happened in the economy and I could
guarantee them as everyone else could
lots of bad things were going to happen
in the economy so the question was did
you want to be blamed for them because
if you voted for the tarp and bad things
happen well guess what really bad things
have happened I haven't heard anyone
blamed for it has anyone heard a member
of Congress blame for that you idiot you
voted for the
look what happened I haven't seen anyone
blamed for that so they created a
situation where members of Congress had
the option you could either vote for the
tarp and you're fine you don't have to
worry about a thing or you could vote
against it and if it goes down you're
going to be blamed for every bad thing
that happens well no member the right
mind they obviously care about being
reelected I mean not to say they don't
care about something else but they don't
get reelected they don't have a job they
care about being elected that meant they
voted for the tarp that meant there was
no way it was going to go down at the
end of the day so I let's see the other
part of your question I just you know
looking at the options yeah I just say
that I don't see an option to try and
save this system I don't there's not
another one out there that I see if I
saw another one out there I might talk
about it but I don't see another one so
in terms of the best thing progressives
could do ya I think trying to save this
system make it work for people as best
we can is the best thing we could do
thank you a comment you made disturb me
a little bit you said that people were
the Republicans were joking or teasing
or ridiculing Democrats for being taxed
and spenders and and of course that's an
old jibe and ridicule is a very powerful
tool in in politics and so I long ago
actually came up with a counter slogan
of taxes that could be applied towards
that side calling them tax ins and and
steel and I think that this this bailout
that that first went in under Bush you
know before he was out of office where
there weren't even any stipulations on
it as to how they spend the money and
they're now refusing to explain how they
spent the money sort of underscores that
that that was going on are you I you had
mentioned that you're in you definitely
want to see this new bailout go through
or this new you know spending plan go
through and fast I think there's a lot
of concern out there that it's going
through too fast without proper review
well it's legitimate question I I think
when i was saying about spending i'm
actually not a person
we should spend all the time my other
book the the conservative nanny state
I'm actually arguing that we shouldn't
be thinking of the government as being
big spenders because I in some ways I
think conservatives had a lot of good
points there this is an extraordinary
time though I mean that so when I was
saying that we want to spend money I
literally mean that we want to spend
money so if we have an option option a
is spend a hundred billion on this
program or we could spend 150 and
hopefully accomplish more for the
hundred fifty I'd rather spend 150 this
is not the time where you're trying to
do things as cheaply as possible we
literally want to spend money we want to
get on the economy we want to employ
people now again we want to be as well
spent as possible so can we have better
safeguards in there we should try to
have the best safeguards as possible but
at this point we are losing jobs so
rapidly the idea that we're going to sit
around and take I don't know two weeks
even but it could well be a month two
months if you don't have a very pressing
deadlines that you're determined to
stick to well the way Congress works
it's easy to just keep rolling and
rolling the rolling and we really need
that money i mean i think it was really
unfortunate that you couldn't even
negotiate something with bush that
before he left office he would give
there must been something he would agree
to i don't i don't know i don't always
doing it on personal contact with them
but presumably to agree to give some
money to the states you know they're the
republican states too so you know so
they don't have to start laying off
people cut back services i mean this is
this is going on and if we don't have
money from Congress very quickly state
and local governments you're going to
see another round of layoffs and you've
already seen a lot here and DC and
virginia maryland butts all across the
country if we don't get money to those
states real soon they're going to be
laying off people left and right so i
don't think we have the luxury of saying
how can we make sure it's best spent we
really do have to spend it so obviously
we should try as much as possible in our
safeguards in there if you read through
the bill i think they've done a pretty
good job of trying to put in safeguards
there will be corruption i mean i'll
guarantee you you're spending eight
hundred billion you're going to find you
know the governor or mayor someone who
gave a contract to his brother even
though it costs twice as much that's
going to happen but what we have to try
and do is make sure that that happens as
little as possible and as i say i think
that's a small price to pay for keeping
the economy going thank you
Thank You mr. Baker I'm I'm from Japan
paisan nakanishi my English is so
terrible sorry everyone and I like to
ask two questions one is can we do the
can we manage the economy without a
bubble for the future and the second is
the net are does the United States
economy continue to dara's a creation
from China or Japan or something like
that you repeat the last pair the second
question does it continue to general
circulation Imperial circulation
circulation circulation saturation
current ah ah they have a large current
account deficit yes yes okay okay so can
we have the first question about a
bubble I think we can restore a path of
healthy growth we just have to have
different priorities a different source
structure I mean if we can get back to a
situation where we have workers sharing
and productivity growth seeing wage
gains in step with productivity growth I
think we can have healthy economic
growth and out of bubbles again we did
that for a long period after World War 2
45 well into the 70s before we have
problems stemming from OPEC price
increases a number of other issues but
we had a long period of very healthy
growth no bubbles that were of any major
consequence so I think it is possible to
get back there now in terms of the
United States and current account
deficit no I mean I think this is a
really big problem and it's one of
things I was remarkable that you have
all these people go over the Washington
Post i call them fox on 15th they're
absolutely obsessed with the budget
deficit i mean just crazy they're
absolutely obsessed with the budget
deficit they write endless pieces on the
day after day the economy could be going
through the floor and they're going to
be writing about the budget deficit i
mean it's crazy but when it comes to the
trade deficit which was always much
larger at least through the last decade
than the budget deficit they had nothing
to say about it they'd find a story may
be buried somewhere in their business
section there editorials didn't notice
it we have this huge trade deficit which
is it it led it
played a very big role in the imbalances
that led this door open for the housing
bubble so we probably can't sustain the
trade deficit for much longer I mean a
lot depends on what China's willing to
do they adopted this growth path that
was very heavily dependent on exports
the United States my guess is that
they're going to be looking to a much
more internal of process that's much
more dependent on internal development
domestic consumption we'll have to see
but I really don't expect them to be
willing to in effect lend us money at
almost no return indefinitely into the
future so my guess is we're not going to
have this pattern where we have this
huge trade deficit much longer and as a
matter of policy obviously the US has
some role in this they act like we're
totally at the mercy of these other
countries we're begging them or going to
cajole them we're going to threaten them
we could set a price for the dollar just
like they set a price for their currency
I mean the one I'd have to go look where
it stands today but let's say it's six
to a dollar if we think that that's
undervalued we could say well guess what
the Treasury will give you a dollar for
41 we could do that we could do that and
if they you have a war that way I can
tell you they lose they end up paying an
awful lot of money for dollars that they
don't want so ideally you would never
get there you get negotiations and you
end up on some path of they raise the
value of their currency but I think it
is very important to get our dollar down
get get it more in line with where it
should be and that would allow our trade
deficit to move to a sustainable level
we don't have to balance trade just like
we don't have a balanced budget but
something close to that maybe I agree
with all your points night about the the
housing bubble and the need to shrink a
financial sector but I was wondering
about oil prices and fuel prices and do
you think how big of a role do you think
of the that played in this this crisis
because if you look at previous run
quick very rapid run ups and fuel prices
like OPEC one and OPEC to you find that
they start to grainger cause and if you
run as far as and things of that that
sort you find that they have a big
effect on industrial production so do
you think that that was kind of the
thing that started this whole thing kind
of tumbling down or what do you think of
the role that fuel price rises played in
this crisis it's a real good question i
think you had is obviously speculation
in few
that was the same sort of speculation
that led to the housing bubble I don't
think it played a major role during
during the winter this year in spring
when he had gas prices crossing four
dollars a gallon obviously it was it was
putting downward pressure on the economy
pulling money out of people's pocket but
I think at most that might have affected
the timing because the collapse is
already underway pulling money on
people's pocket at that point in time
probably facilitated the collapse and
that was harder for people make ends
meet on their mortgages so probably
hasten the the rate of foreclosure and
defaults but I don't I don't think it
was really central to the story every
everything that we saw happen would have
happened even if we didn't have that
spike in oil pro you're a economist not
a psychiatrist but what could Ruben and
no bondsman Greenspan have been thinking
how do they think this would have turned
out that's a good question um I it's
very hard to match I mean you always
wonder when someone's so completely off
the mark like that thank you
excuse me when someone so completely off
the mark like that in a way that I would
say not just in retrospect but at the
time should have been evident how they
could have missed that the only thing
that this is obviously tall speculation
I've never been met Alan Greenspan I
guess I've been in a room with Robert
Rubin a couple times but one claims to
know them at all that if everyone if you
get basically everyone being sort of an
a clot everyone's saying well you're
such a brilliant person you never really
think about these things you just keep
repeating them and with Ruben I have
this joke which maybe maybe my dream has
finally come true I've been meeting
several times around DC like with
congressional staffers and other types
and we'll be discussing some issues
social security or the budget and some
will go well what does Bob say about
this and of course Rubens not in the
wrong I mean though and everyone you
know some will speak up well I know that
Reuben or Bob would say x y&z and
everyone gives that great respect so
I've always said that my goal in my work
here my time here in Washington was to
get Bob out of the room and we may have
done that we may have done that so but I
really can't tell you how could he not
see this I really don't know it's it's
it's a good question maybe one of these
days they'll be forthright and say what
they were actually thinking about all
this and I'm happy to hear some pointed
criticism of Alan Greenspan because it
seemed as though there's this
inexplicable adulation forum in spite of
a number of very aggressive decisions
he's made in policies that is that he's
stuck to my question relates to that and
speaks to your last point about the
influence of the financial sector on
public policy making and there seems to
be a well-established funnel of banking
executives into the public sector and I
think that's had a heavy hand in leading
to this crisis and I don't see any signs
of that changing so i suppose what do
you think may may lead to that change i
mean has some of their errors will that
result in enough pressure being put on
on the system to you know
correct that that funneled to to to cut
back on this undue influence and what do
you project for in a future financial
policy making well first off I'd
absolutely agree it is a serious problem
and again speaking to where things stand
with the Obama administration I happen
to see a list of Timothy Geithner
appointed appointments as assistants
that just filled chock-full of Wall
Street people and there is this idea
that somehow there in a privileged
position to run the economy and and and
the attitudes are just amazing the henry
paulson of course was a former head of
Goldman Sachs as was robert rubin before
i came to treasury and then he left and
went to citibank but paulson this is a
front-page article in the new york times
when he made the decision to rescue AIG
he had the current head of Goldman Sachs
in the room now the reason why that was
so striking is AIG owed Goldman Sachs
somewhere in the order 20 billion
dollars and obviously they didn't see
anything improper about this or they
want to had it and you just think of
this imagine there's a court case you're
in small claims court and someone
wrecked your car and you're suing them
for five thousand dollars because you
you want them to pay for wrecking your
car and judge is deciding on the case
and you're sitting in the room with the
judge when the judge makes it well
everyone say that you weren't supposed
to be there now maybe the judge would
make the exact same decision anyhow but
you're it looks bad and in this case
it's not five thousands 20 billion but
it tend to occur to them that there was
something a proper about that because
you know we're all such good people here
and again maybe Paulson I think he made
the right decision for the right guy
thing he made the right decision rescue
edgy but you know and he may have made
the same decision whether or not the
skies is friend or acquaintance or
business partner but it just stinks and
this idea that somehow you have these
people in finance that are uniquely
qualified to run the economy is very
very disturbing now how do you change
that well we really have to go after
them and now is the time because they've
wrecked the economy and it's just
remarkable to me that these people have
any standing again beating up on my
friend Robert Rubin I think of you know
during the campaign Obama didn't want to
be seen near his farm Minister Reverend
right that was pariah you can't be near
him or Bill Ayers you know because the
good what the guy had done 40 years ago
well
he should want to be seen anywhere near
Robert Rubin either and that that should
be people's view of the financial
industry right now not that everyone
there is a crook but an awful long as
people are and they did a lot of things
that wrecked real havoc on the economy
and ruin people's lives so the idea that
they're somehow specially placed be
running the economy that that doesn't
make a lot of sense now are we going to
be able to chase them out it's a tough
one I mean you do it's been starting him
in in my column beat the press is a
column of media criticism so I followed
the reporting very very closely and one
of things have been very pleased by is
looking at some of the reporting
certainly the New York Times I'll point
I'll hold them up I've trashed in New
York Times many many times but I'll
price them here they have a number of
reporters who've earned outstanding
pieces reporting on conserve the wrong
dealings of the major banks you know
city bank Goldman you know they've
really gotten into the nuts and bolts of
this I'd like to see a lot more of that
because I think people don't fully
appreciate they still don't fully
appreciate how this was totally
preventable it was through people's
greed through their a combination of
greed and stupidity that that we really
got here and people have every right in
the world to be absolutely furious at
these people
so my question is what does it mean that
the u.s. government will be taking over
or as considering taking over be of a
and citibank what does that mean to us
and do you agree with that well I do
agree with the government taking over
the banks that are insolvent I mean
basically the story that we had had in n
tarp one was that you had institutions
are essentially in solvent they're
bankrupt not to mince words they're
bankrupt okay if we're just left to that
they said we should leave things to the
market we left things to the market we'd
have a bankruptcy judge would be
deciding how citigroup is run right now
same probably a bank of america and many
of the other banks we don't want to do
that with banks because banks have a
unique position the economy we have all
these deposits short-term deposits it
would be very difficult to envision a
bankruptcy judge overseeing a bank at
least a major bank we could probably do
with a minor one without difficulty but
for the major banks our economy that be
a very hard thing to do so we have to
keep them in operation so question is do
you just hand them taxpayer dollars
which has basically been what we've been
doing to date or do you say no you're
bankrupt we're going to take you over
we're going to get your books in order
and there's been talk about a bad bank
that makes a lot of sense we actually
did this in the 80s it's not radical
concept the Resolution Trust Corporation
we did this with the SNL's in the 80s we
took over the bankrupt SNL's we took
their bad assets through them over the
Resolution Trust Corporation sold them
off and got what money we could for them
and with with the remaining SNL's we got
their books in order and we reorganize
them and we sold them off back to the
private sector I'm not anxious to see
the government run the banks I'd rather
not take them over but if the
alternative is the tax people you know I
want to get Joe the plumber here hey Joe
how do you feel about paying higher
taxes so that Robert Rubin can continue
draw a high salary at citibank is that
what you want you know because that's
what we're talking about so I find that
a very very hard line to push I mean I
really find it reprehensible about every
different angle so given that the banks
or at least a very large number of them
are bankrupt I don't see an option but
to have the government take them over
replace the management get rid of the
bad assets and then resell them to the
private sector I really don't see a
serious option to that
okay i want to thank everybody for
coming out tonight and let's thank ours
our speaker Dean Baker one more time
Dean Baker is co-director of the Center
for Economic and Policy Research in
Washington DC mr. Baker has authored
several books including the conservative
nanny state